[Music]
in Frank Herbert's 1960 sci-fi series
dune that laylax ooh are an extremely
secretive group of humans who live on
the planet to laylax which is the only
planet circling the star thalam the
trail Axew our genetically altered and
in general that lilacs ooh are despised
by the other inhabitants of the known
universe due to their shady ethics and
customs their civilization is separated
into different classes each of which
have distinct physical appearances and
roles within society the Tleilaxu
masters the ruling class with their
small close-set eyes and pointed teeth
the axolotl tinks who are the remnants
of the female sex of the clay Lac soon
their sole purpose is to breed they are
no more than incubation vessels and
there are the face dancers the working
class and a warrior class they are
capable of adapting their physical
appearance their ability to copy the
exact appearance of another is often
used by the been each laylax to spy on
other groups in the Imperium the
Tleilaxu were hated because it was
generally believed that their genetic
manipulation masked life and nature
whilst groups like the bene Jesuit could
be tolerated
the Tleilaxu inspired primal horror most
facts about the religion of the clay Lac
zoo was not revealed until the arrival
of the honored matriz they follow a
fervent spiritual ideology that was
formed from multiple other theologies
like most cultures within the known
universe their faith is monotheistic
using their axolotl tanks the many to
laylax
are also able to produce goalless
goalless are artificially created humans
who have been redrawn from as little as
a cell from an original human being
though a Gola may appear similar to a
clone
there are a few crucial distinctions the
original golas in Frank Herbert's dune
series possessed artificial metallic
eyes unlike loans goalless could
eventually possess most if not all of
the memories of the source human and
most importantly for one to be
considered a ghola the cells must be
collected after the original human was
already dead
the gola would possess a death memory
once the original memories had been
restored the main Gola of the doom saga
is Duncan Idaho who first appears in
book 1 and returns as multiple golus
throughout the series over the course of
thousands of years the original Duncan
Idaho was a Swords master in service to
House Atreides he returns as a gola in
dune Messiah as a gift to Emperor Paul
Atreides from the Binet laylax the key
trait of the Binet laylax
is their extreme xenophobia anyone not
born on their planet is considered a POW
winda a derogatory term meaning
non-believer the culture of the Binet
laylax was built around isolationism not
simply spatially but genetically as well
the till a lack su had long focused
their efforts on genetics and the
pursuit of spiritual elevation through
physical refinement that sleigh lacks uu
civilization would eventually fall to
the hands of the honored mantras of the
scattering who seek trve in John alter
laylax uu males the banette laylax
are involved in several schemes and
plots throughout the dune series at one
point even attempting to assassinate the
god emperor Leto ii himself the till a
lack su like the guild navigators been
the definition of what it means to be
human
their society is a dark window into what
happens when nationalism is taken to the
extreme
you